can i get your take since we're on it
are you putting your money on wilder or
i don't know i go back and forth i have
this weird thing i don't know what it is
that wilder i said this last time that
wilder might clip them but i don't know
while there's a new he's working his jab
a lot apparently and there's not enough
hours in the day to get a jab to beat
tyson fury what does he look good though
wow that looks wilder he missed so
stupid muscular like he just looks like
he's put on
crazy muscular
shape too which is trouble trouble
but wilder is the best
yeah he is another problem is last time
they fought he got like he didn't get
beat he has got dismantled yeah
it's like when florida atlantic plays
alabama at least 70 to zero like dude
they're that one there you go look at
this look at him
look at the like he's got a towel how
tall is he got his dick root in our face
but just why ever wear clothes i would i
would never wear clothes i would never
wear clothes he's such a good dude i
think it's i think it'd be good for
boxing if you won because then you get a
fourth fight
and then the loser and we'll see what
contractually if anthony joshua still
wants to do it you get anthony joshua
fights the loser you tell me what watch
let's say deonta water loses and vegas
is right you went watch deontay wilder
and [ __ ] anthony joshua and then the
winner that gets to
[ __ ] go against fury again all so the
three of them are all gonna make so much
money do the three were making money
because
yeah joshua lost the guy who beat him
usyk
we don't care all we care about is those
three
when they win or lose all we care about
those three but but don't you feel like
usyk is in that mix isn't he gonna well
it's gonna be mandatory you're gonna
have because he took all the belts i
know so you're gonna make it mandatory
but that's not the money five well i
don't i think he's too small to beat
wilder i mean fury i mean and i think
that he stands uh
ustic is a better boxer technically he's
better than all of them
right now even better than fury yeah
yeah yeah just phenomenal he's
fundamental but he's much he's smaller
but he is 220 that's big enough
but he's just not going to does not guys
win rounds and heavyweights lose rounds
like usyk with his cardio he can you
know heavyweights will feel each other
out it really any boxer will
feel each other out for six rounds yup
that's a problem with boxing do don't do
12 rounds so they feel because it you
know it's a science so they feel each
other out for you know four to five
rounds and then the fight starts
happening in the sixth round start
figuring each other out don't have to do
that against these big boys he can win
those first six rounds yeah he he goes
to work uh-huh yeah wow he's not trying
he knows he's going to the distance he's
not going to knock these guys out so
he's just getting so he's going to get
those points yeah
it's trouble and he's southpaw paying
the ass but
but
wilder he's never been hit like you got
like wilder so if that lands i was
thinking about that because he does
stand with his hands up he stands in
your grill i know his heads are moving
but but joshua can hit too though yeah
but while that didn't seem to i mean
joshua didn't seem to unload
to me joshua didn't he doesn't seem to
want he i think he's rich and happy and
he's good he didn't but but it also if
you're joshua think about it
the fight between him and fear was
supposed to happen and then wilder comes
in and forces a trilogy fight for
literally went to court and forced it so
if you're joshua and you get ready for
tyson fury and then that's the biggest
fight in english history really ever
ever history ever you know what i'm
saying like the biggest superstar ever
so big so
and that gets taken from you and then as
good as usyk is it's not like a main
fight so i think
he was just like coasting it in and it's
unfortunate
unless you're a boxing fan nobody even
knows who is like if you're a boxer you
know who he is of course he's a [ __ ]
mom
but if you're a box fan too you're like
ooh that's trouble for joshua
the guy's a [ __ ] savage i don't know
why he's i guess his did his camp have
to take those two yeah it's mandatory
yeah when you own when you have those
belts it's mandatory my thing about
joshua is he seemed just fine losing he
didn't seem
upset about it he seemed
and again i think you're right i think
maybe sometimes people have the person
who can deal with being a superstar and
super rich is canelo the guy who might
not be able to is with so many other
options is joshua he's got he's just a
superstar he's been doing for a while
and remember when he you gotta remember
when he does wembley stadium out there
you talking about what hundred ten
thousand tickets it's a lot of pressure
he also lost to a really good guy by the
way who took it but then remember he
also asked the ruiz
another fight that was flying under the
radar he said god i guess i'll fight
this fat mexican and then lost yep
i would was he upset about that if i
were
he redeemed himself and beat the [ __ ]
out of him yeah he's just so big and
strong you just think just just use your
size and power through that and just
punch the [ __ ] you know watch on
saturday are you you're on the road this
weekend i'm gonna be in uh columbus i'm
in ohio
when it's going down
columbus funny bone come see me friday
it's so nice when uh the the like i know
i have time yeah before the main event
you know i can watch him like oh thank
god but how many times have i i've been
watching i'll tell chappelle my dude
yeah and then when i do the meet and
greet people are ruining it for me dude
you know what happens wild or fear i'm
like i didn't i had to come out here
during the second round please tell me
what happened
fury got knocked out and that's how i
find out i'm like don't tell me don't
tell me you want to know well that
doesn't work the robbie lawler they
don't tell me oh yeah because they go on
their phones like right after the show's
over and then
yeah all right so this is this this
saturday wow
i'm so excited it's gonna be amazing
what time first big fight and i mean no
standard [ __ ] dude probably nine they'll
probably walk around nine that's the
interesting thing about boxing is if
you know in ufc if the first on the main
card if the first four fights are
knockouts in 10 seconds it doesn't
matter that main event is going yeah
that's right in boxing no dude like
canelo he'll make [ __ ] wait two hours
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] no like this
one even if a fight like is a quick
fight doesn't matter they have to fill
time yeah you know boxing like played by
pioneers is a beast because those fights
dude go quick
they have to fill time yeah because
they're like no kid canelo or floyd
mayweather they they walk at nine yeah
like they're warming up good luck go
tell them to come out here get them
they walk at night no matter what ufc's
decide oh yeah that's why like when i
was fighting the fc like you'd look at
the three fights before you and if it's
like lighter weights you're like right
have some time if it was like knock out
or say god [ __ ] everybody ready to go
man oh did you ever see anybody in the
ufc when they're before they ran a fight
was that were there any locker rooms
that were just completely relaxed and
look you know not like logan paul
you know you're about to fight right you
didn't give a [ __ ] that's that's that's
like that's a gallows mood there like
when you're in when right before you're
gonna fight that [ __ ] is tense yeah it's
like uh it's like uh gladiator remember
they're all waiting that guy pisses his
pants because they're chained together
yeah that's what it's like you're like
staring at each other all right seeing
that you're about to fight that person
they're like well going out there
all right fellas
and then you're so jealous of the person
that went out before you and won and
came back in like oh you're so lucky god
i'm so jealous of it
yeah i don't know that [ __ ] is just i
wonder i would imagine
well i feel like fury's not like that
he's nervous like what oh he's also but
he he's been doing it for so that's
that's my issue picking wilder but
listen i'm betting man i like money so
the bet is wilder under 12 rounds via
knockout to make money you parliament
that's the money that's how you make
money because you're better if you're
not making money so if you want to make
money bet on wilder but it's like
there's not enough days in the week
there's nothing to change your style to
change use that jazz catch up to fury
he's been boxing since he's
four-year-olds in diapers he's got he's
a gypsy yeah he's named after mike tyson
yeah yeah so it's just he speaks that
language and it's like if you were
fluent in spanish and then you know
we're gonna debate each other like but
it's in spanish brandon you have six
months like i kind of know spanish oh
yeah so it's like let me let me let me
hire like it doesn't matter well he has
to know that that brings your weaknesses
he's gonna try to do exactly what he did
in the second fight which is get him on
his back foot and just smother him maybe
you don't have to do that you don't have
to do it no because he can do he can do
it all yeah
although
that's what louder is expecting them
yeah so but you fury's gonna mess with
him for a little bit and then apply the
pressure because he knows how dangerous
deontay is so many things such a good
fight so i can't it's exciting boxing is
so exciting right now when it's high
level there's nothing better when it's
people you don't know there's nothing
worse
yeah that i just like mma good i mean
mma is like pizza cold hot i'll [ __ ]
i mean people get [ __ ] up all the time
yeah even if guy has real shitty skill
it's still fun to watch
boxing though because those guys they
don't have like four fights on tv if
they're on tv and you don't know who
they are even though they're so
technical might have won a [ __ ] gold
medal in the olympics yeah all right
it's just it's like golf i know